[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
welcome walter hi martin we've made it
this is the last one in the series
understanding pope francis yes
this will be the final book end to put
the series together
so let's open with the word of prayer
our heavenly father thank you very much
for giving us the opportunity to have
discussed this whole series
of deceit and we ask that you
help us in this last one and enlighten
our minds with the holy spirit
that we can use this knowledge to
further it to the
glorification of your kingdom in jesus
name amen
amen
now we have to pull it together
so again we'll be doing a little bit of
history
and bringing it to the present time
so i think this one
should bring us right up to where we are
now in the stream of time
so we've titled it understanding pope
francis
lauda to see gaia worship the great
reset
nothing new because people think you
know this is now
because of the crisis in the climate and
the crisis in this that this is all
developing brand new right now no
this is old planning
that is coming to fruition correct they
want to give it a title
the new normal but this has been planned
long time ago so let's start off with
this
verse in ecclesiastes one verse nine
the thing that has been it is that which
shall be and that which is done is that
which shall be done and there is no
new thing under the sun
i think that'll sum it up right correct
so let's go back to history
go back a couple of years and let's see
where we can find the root of the
planning
that is now coming to fruition
unsaid united nations conference
environment development
onset also called the earth summit
was an unveiling of the philosophical
shift from the judea
christian worldview to gaia
the program of action called agenda 21
is 297 pages long
and a second related document global
assessment is over 1
100 pages long together these documents
contain an agenda that can only be
called
evil as the implementation of the
action items will turn
freedom into bondage and life into
misery as all of what we know today
will be replaced by a planned
electronic society
in which our only value will be to
produce this was written
in 1998
right long before any of this
appeared even even that was
in the beginning of the electronic
current in it era in feudalistic
times only the king and nobility
owned land and had freedom
so too under united nations rule
feudalistic times will return
and the lights of freedom will go out
with the adoption of sustainable
development at unsaid
man was demoted to the same level as a
plant or an animal
so this whole question of sustainable
development
and earth related summits
was something that took place in
the stream of history and now
the modern world the scientific world
the political world and the religious
world under pope francis
are pulling it together now martin it is
so sad to me
that churches today will be so
involved in the sustainable development
and climate change agenda
that they will hold summits for the
youth
to concentrate on these issues when the
world
is standing before the second coming of
christ
and they are involved in this kind of
thing
even within our own ranks now it's very
sad
it's very sad because like you just
mentioned
our focus is to now to get people ready
for the second coming not trying to
educate them on how
to save this and save that around it's
based on a lie
it's based on pagan philosophy
so if we have a look at some of the the
issues
they had certain goals millennium end
goals were first
prepared for the 2015.
so high-level events on the millennium
development goals united nations
headquarters
2008 media advisory world leaders to
boost
action to end extreme poverty at the
united nations high-level event 25
september now this issue of
and extreme poverty is this a song that
pope francis loves to sing oh yes
definitely
so it's an old song so let's just go
back in history martin and look at this
gaia hypothesis
yeah now according to john verne
james lovelock formulated the gaia
hypothesis which today
is known as the worship of the earth
it propagates holism which perverts
and inverts genesis 1
holism is evolution at its finest
man evolves to the point where he's
equal
with the earth the plants and the
animals
and the environment is elevated to a
position of dominance of a man
this is earth worship it's also
pantheism
and it inverts genesis chapter one
which is the very beginning of the
blueprint
for humanity yes any religion
that inverts genesis 1 is paganism
the only way to change the laws of every
country
and to take control is to make the
environment the focal point
eventually the world will be ruled by
global governance
partnership between business the private
sector and government
which is fascism that's the definition
of fascism
now this comes from jones vern
prince charles the sustainable prince
published in 1998 it's a very
interesting book
well it's very spot-on it's very
prophetic
one could almost say right so when you
look at something from
a christian perspective and you really
start studying
what is happening in the occult world
you cannot but
notice that everything in the world is
an inversion
that's why i call the devil the master
of reversal
so if god puts a hierarchy into the
world the devil will turn it around
if god puts the parents above the
children
in terms of training the world will turn
around and make
yes law higher than parental
right right so that's just the way
it works gender reversal
and of course environment humanity
reversal in the bible yes man is put in
charge of the environment
in the reversal the environment takes
precedence and man
has to be subjugated to its rule
yes that's paganism and the champion of
it
is the papacy yes lauda to see
is nothing other than this pagan agenda
100 but i also enjoy it here is the only
way to change the laws of
every country yes is to contact
to get this environment you need a
universal problem
if you can use a universal pandemic
and if you can use a universal climate
catastrophe
then you have everything in place are we
capable of manipulating the weather
well yes does it say in the spirit of
prophecy
that the evil world has studied the laws
of nature
and knows how to manipulate the weather
yes satan is using his agents
to manipulate weather for sure and he
does it himself sometimes
what did he do in the time of job yes
what swept away the belongings and the
family of job
a mighty storm right mighty storm yes
so this is ancient history so let's have
a look at the definition of sustainable
development
development that meets the needs of the
present without
compromising the ability of future
generation to meet their own needs
so there are two concepts here needs
as it pertains to the world's poor
to which overriding priority should be
given
and secondly the idea of limitations
imposed by technology
on the environment's ability to meet
present and future needs
at a minimum sustainable development
must not
endanger the natural systems that
support life on earth
atmosphere water soils living beings
now the concept of sustainable
development in itself is not a bad
concept no
because you don't want to destroy
resources without being able
to supply future resources
but the way in which it is done is
fascinating
because who owns the mega corporations
that have destroyed
the ecosystem wrong the knights of malta
yes
and their association eventually it goes
back to rome yes
it goes back to rome who controls the
economies
so this license
this free-for-all for destruction comes
from a particular source that is now
saying we need this and that and the
other
so they're always hiding in the
background it's like when
the pope is always emphasizing we have
to look after the poor
and all of this it's not it's not a bad
concept
the bible is full of it but the problem
is
they make that they put that in front
they make that the
main issue on that's going on
now when the bible speaks about the poor
it does speak about the physical poor
but largely it's speaking about those
that are
poor in spirit in other words that are
depressed now you can be very rich
and you can be very depressed and you
can
be trodden upon i mean in the last one
that we looked at
we saw some of these stars and we
mentioned britney spears and all of
these
they are not happy they are poor in
spirit
they need to be reached with the gospel
of salvation as much as
anybody else correct so when we see
these people
with all their hand signatures and
all this symbolism correct we mustn't
want to ostracize them
your heart must go out to them like
jesus you must try and reach them
do you know martin i've had occasions
when in my audience there were film
stars
that realized that they had been
duped and they've changed their ways
actors opera singers
many many people that have realized
what this all led to you know we're off
the topic now in our previous topic
but uh it's fascinating to me that they
use
such illustrious names the order of
saint
john i mean if you if you want to choose
two of the saints that are probably
invoked the most by catholicism
then it's saint john referring to john
the baptist
and saint paul yes everything at saint
paul's cathedral saint paul's
this paul that the other and john john
john no matter where you turn
and you think well this is wonderful ask
yourself the question
what was the message of john the baptist
the message of john the baptist is what
we are talking about
here which is the exact opposite of what
they are doing he's preparing for the
second coming yes was for the preparing
for the first coming correct
but that is the name they invoke the
message of saint paul
the absolute beauty of the plan of
salvation as explained by paul in the
bible
the atonement what it meant the high
priestly role of jesus christ
is that portrayed in what they are
saying or the exact opposite the exact
opposite
now i've often thought modern why do
they like those two names the most
because if you go into the heart of
these occult societies
one of their punishments
for breaking the oath is beheading
so they make beheading one
of the parts
of their ritual and both john the
baptist
and paul were beheaded yes
so when they're talking about these are
they celebrating
what they stood for obviously not no or
are they celebrating
a victory of evil over them by beheading
them
yep so we have to note that nothing is
as it seems exactly
because if they really were following
john the baptist and if they really were
following the teachings of paul
they would not be doing what they are
doing let's get back to this
agenda 21 sets up the global
infrastructure needed to
manage count and control
all the world's assets pastures
range land farmers field
oceans inland waterways marine
environment
marine life cities housing sewer solid
waste methods of production
air pollution biotechnology every aspect
of living farming production and
manufacturing
research and medicine etc etc
along with you and me
is this what is happening in the world
which philanthropist owns the greatest
quantity of pastures
and farmland in the world today
well because he's not british we can't
call him sir
but that will be bill gates but he was
knighted but he was knighted
isn't that interesting so if you
grab all the means in a particular
area then you create mega
corporations and you create mega control
it's interesting that also
the world's assets with whom did
pope francis have that big gathering
a few months ago correct with all the
big businesses and the capital
mastercard and all these big financing
houses correct
and they are controlling every aspect
and they will take away your land and
you will
own nothing as a result of advanced
technology through computers and
satellites
the geographic information system gis
the management count and control is
being done
number one the convention on biological
diversity which puts
holism into practice
now we said in a previous one that we
will have all of these
issues we will have a pandemic we'll
have a climate catastrophe
and then we'll have a biodiversity
catastrophe now it's interesting to me
that at the last g7
biodiversity was made prominent
so already they are bringing it in
secondly the convention on
desertification
the convention on climate change these
conventions will change the freedoms we
have known
and our ability to choose what we think
is best for our family and businesses
written in 1998 martin
nothing new under the sun nothing new
this is like
reading it in a paper of today yeah we
have to go to the history to show people
that they're being led by the nose this
is a plan
long time coming
then you have the earth charter
initiative
is a declaration of fundamental
principles for building a just
sustainable and peaceful global society
for the 21st century it sounds like pope
francis speaking
yes created by global civil society
endorsed by
thousands of organizations and
institutions
the charter is not only a call to action
but a
motivating force inspiring change
the world over this is a pagan agenda
yes this is a pagan agenda it is
directly opposed to the word of god
in 1992 morris strong was the secretary
general
of the historic united nations unsaid
earth conference in rio and he said
the real goal of the earth charter is
that it will
in fact become like the ten commandments
so i wonder whose ten commandments
martin
the bibles or the popes well all of this
leads back to rome so definitely not the
bible definitely not
and then mikhail gorbachev said do not
do unto the environment
of others what you do not want done to
your own
environment my hope is that this charter
will be a kind of ten commandments
a sermon on the mount that provides a
guide for human behavior towards the
environment in the next century in 1997
that
yes coming out of a communist atheist
regime it's interesting how they want to
replace
the standard of the bible with another
standard yes
and then they even use biblical language
sermon on the mount
but they totally opposed to that
absolutely then he hinted morris strong
at the overtly pagan agenda proposed for
a future a
charter when in his opening address to
the rio conference he said
it is the responsibility of each human
being today
to choose between the force of darkness
and the force of light
now we've heard this from the mouths of
presidents
in many speeches of late yes we must
choose light
and not darkness who was the light
bearer
lucifer now we did that one on
the knighthoods yes and we saw
the issue of the rain man yes we didn't
even talk about
movies like rain man etc etc
but i think enough was said notice
alice a bailly and blavatsky before her
use these terms often their writings
state that the force of
darkness are those who adhere to the
outdated judeo-christian
faith those who continue along their
separative paths
of the one true god that's outdated
martin
light has to become darkness darkness
has to become light
we have to have a reversal and
blavatsky makes no bones about it that
the source of light is lucifer and the
source of darkness is jesus christ
and this becomes very dangerous when you
go into what's happening in our day
because
there's a lot of talks about movements
and people
saying there needs to come this great
awakening
and that all this evil has to be done
away with
what is this evil the judeo-christian
culture
but even if you've got the other side if
you look at the way blavatsky was
talking
you've got white and black magic black
magic can also be evil
white magic seems to be good but it's
still magic
correct and that's where the danger lies
about a lot of this that's happening
like the q
anon movement correct it looks like
they're going to do it for the benefit
of god but in the meantime it's
another god another god it's like white
magic you know what
the only form of christianity that will
be allowed to be part of this
new world order will be a christianity
that has replaced the norms and
standards of the bible
with this gaia hypothesis environmental
issue that's why we must avoid it like
the plague
now is the time to preach the gospel
not to climb onto a papal train
leading you to petition and no leader
that will become president in the near
future
will not be part of the new world order
correct even if it seems that he is not
correct
because nothing is as it seems nothing
is as it seems now you know if you go
back to the book of daniel
then you'll see what the issues were
there i mean the book of daniel is a
beautiful book it shows you exactly what
the issues will be you will have to bow
down to
a system of worship that is contrary to
the bible
diet will be involved in a very specific
way
music will be evolved when you hear the
sound of the flute
music will be involved we see all of
this in the world today
and this part of come out and be
separate
is not going to be acceptable so the
force of light
lucifer in their view is the inclusive
new age doctrine of a pagan pantheistic
new world religion
in the new age of aquarius there will be
no room for the force of darkness
and separativeness
we must therefore transform our
attitudes and adopt a
renewed respect for the superior laws of
divine
nature that's natural law we've shown
we've shown that all along strong
finished with unanimous applause from
the crowd
quoted in joan burns prince charles the
sustainable prince so there you have the
full catastrophe
paganism takes the place of christianity
i can see it in the nations i can see it
in the laws
yes i don't it doesn't matter whether
we're looking at our own country
or whether we're looking at the united
states of america exactly
or whether we're looking at the europe
it doesn't matter
everywhere it is exactly the same
then the humanist manifesto states quite
clearly
in order that religious humanism may be
better understood we the undesigned
desire to make certain affirmations
which we believe the fact of our
contemporary life
demonstrate we therefore affirm the
following
first religious humanists regard the
universe as self-existing
and not created second
humanism believes that man is a part of
nature and that he has emerged as the
result of a continual
process which is called evolution
is the papacy for or against evolution
four wasn't that the jesuit that
introduced the big bang theory
correct man is at last becoming aware
that he is alone responsible for the
realization of the world of his dreams
that he has within himself the power for
this
achievement he must set intelligence and
will to the task this comes from the
humanist manifesto
now question didn't pope paul vi
say exactly the same at vatican ii yes
perfectly so there's nothing new under
the sun here
for this great achievement man utilizing
the resources and the laws of nature yet
without divine aid
can take full credit similarly for his
shortcomings he must take full
responsibility
humanism assigns to man nothing less
than the task
of being his own savior and redeemer
didn't the second vatican council set
the word of god aside
yes and proclaimed themselves their own
redeemers
and included atheists and any pagan
religion whether it is earth worship or
whatever
into its system of worship
definitely all right so this is
basically humanism in action
and many years ago in 2008 already
they were talking about outrageous green
laws gone bad
are we protecting nature or ruining
lives
green laws and regulation risk energy
crisis
i mean we've gone through all of those
and we are now at the point where
presidents close down pipelines yes
destroy jobs and all
in the name of the environment
we are on the brink of very interesting
times
relating to the environment and uh in
canada
they asked the question many years ago
has canada gone mad because if you left
your car idling
you could be slapped with a fine because
you were
wasting non-renewable energy
that's another thing and as we can see
now
laws were implemented worldwide
for climate in preparation yes
so all this talk
[Music]
is already legislated how many countries
are paying carbon tax
all of them you can't buy a car without
paying that tax
correct it's implemented in your fuel
levy
yes the tax levy it's everywhere already
so you don't
even if you don't realize it you've been
part of this climate
environment thing for a very long time
and that tax fuels and funds the united
nations
correct so welcome to oneworld.net we
bring together the latest news and views
of
1 600 organizations
climate justice for this that and the
other
global food crisis all of these
organizations are involved and
all of these organizations and
confederacies
are all probably under the rule of papal
nights
yes so here let's bring it to the
present day
having gone through this history sweep
yeah
march the 3rd 2021 world needs
equivalent of
pandemic lock down every two years to
meet the paris carbon emission goals
so we need a lockdown
it's interesting i just saw a video on
the effect of lockdown
yes how many it was sky news i think
news australia
that said how many people are dying and
committing
suicide as a consequence human life is
of no value
yeah they've actually made it study now
that
more people perished from
lockdowns than it was saving correct
the dramatic drop in global carbon
emissions seen during the early days of
the pandemic and global shutdowns
would need to be matched every two years
for the rest of the
decade in order to meet the goals
outlined in the paris climate agreement
according to a new study
though the authors don't recommend that
the world rely on lockdowns to help
battle climate change but they're
talking about it
yes so let's listen to what the
president of the united states has to
say
on the issue today i'm
pleased to announce a team that will
lead my administration's ambitious plan
to address the existential threat of our
time
climate change folks we're in a crisis
just like we need to be a unified nation
in response to cover 19
we need a unified national response to
climate change
and from this crisis from these crises i
should say
we need to seize the opportunity to
build back and build back better
than we were before a unified
national response it's involuntary
that's the one thing we know
what does it mean well we're learning
that a world health organization
staffers written a report saying that a
climate lockdown
could be called forward it's like a
covert lockdown a climate lockdown
the climate activists were first of all
jealous
when the coveted lockdowns happened they
were beside themselves saying
how is this happening everyone from
greta thunberg to john kerry un
officials
and then they started saying we need to
follow this
if we can shut down for a virus we can
shut down for climate
and that's what we're seeing there's
even academics in australia proposing
adding climate change to death
certificates and bill gates has said the
death toll will be greater so
they're following every step of the way
and it's not just you know a professor
here or someone in academia
we have a major uk report coming out we
have an international agency report that
came out
calling for essentially the same type of
lockdowns
everything from restrictions on your
thermostat to restrictions of moving
uh you know you can only fly in a
climate emergency when it's quote
morally justifiable you know kind of
like a lockdown you have to justify
going to the store for essential
services
they're going after freedom of movement
they're going after private car
ownership
they're going after everything it means
to be a free person and turning it over
to the administrative state
we're not going to be able to have the
freedoms we used to have in the uk they
proposed
co2 ration cards that the government or
employers would monitor
your co2 levels you know your energy use
your travel the type of car you drive
if you exceed a level you pay penalties
if you're under you get
credits this is the world a co2 budget
for every man
woman and child on the planet has been
proposed by a german climate advisor
anything is possible chuck schumer is
urging biden to declare a national
climate emergency
just like a blue state governor he could
have emergency powers
martin do you think god realized what he
was doing when he breathed
into humanity the breath of life
didn't he realize that they were going
to exude carbon dioxide
maybe we should all wear a little
monitor
measuring how much carbon dioxide you
breathe out
don't worry i think that will be in the
future on your mask
it'll be an attachment to the mask your
carbon dioxide meter
and if it if it goes too high what
happens you get a fine or you have to
stop breathing for a week
you're on breath locked down
yeah we can laugh but this is serious
but this is actually what they're doing
right
it is really like this guy just
mentioned
this is not just some to conspiracy
theorists sitting talking about this
this is what's happening in governments
now
absolutely so let's just look at one of
pope francis's earlier statements made
in 2015 already
we wrapped up his south american tour
and he called for a new
economic and ecological world order
again
nothing new under the sun i mean you
know he's living in ecclesiastes it
seems to me
so the goods of the earth are meant for
everyone
and however much someone may parade his
property
or his social mortgage prancer said
the tapping of natural resources which
are so abundant in ecuador must not be
concerned with the short-term benefits
he's going back to thomas aquinas
it's just interesting to see now we've
had the
political side of this whole climate
thing
and now we've got the religious side
with pope francis yes and how this
all fits together fits together and it's
always a negation of the bible
so let's jump to a more modern one of
this 2020. pope francis called for a
just economic
world order as he stands with zimbabwe
now the interesting thing is zimbabwe
was quite a prosperous
country it was the bread basket of
africa it was the bread basket of africa
and now it's the most poverty struck
basket in africa
and who was ruling it a jesuit yes
a jesuit and they managed to destroy it
and it's interesting that the pope bowed
down to him
the only one the only political leader
that he bowed down to because he was an
older jesuit than himself
but the interesting point to me is how
they
allow for this destruction are rewarded
for destroying
because they need to destroy it in order
to get their new system
mugabe was also knighted i think you
might have been stripped of it later but
i mean he was also knighted only for the
public consumption
so you know sometimes people say uh
you know all of this destruction is
because of
incompetence by some people or the other
no
this is planned correct
so then you have the laudato seagulls
and
i mean if you look at them they they are
all encompassing they
encompass education ecological
spirituality community engagement
ecological economics
i mean the list is just endless and the
response to the cry of the earth
now when you read this lauda to see
it is a pagan document it is not much
different from what
unsaid produced at the united nations
the gaia hypothesis
and he starts off with this canticle of
saint francis that reminds us of
this beautiful mother who opens her arms
to embrace us
praise be to you my lord through our
sister
mother earth this is earth worship it's
ridiculous
and this coming from supposedly
christian
pope exactly it is nothing other than
the humanistic
agenda of the gaia hypothesis
who sustains and governs us and who
produces
various fruit with colored flowers and
herbs
classic reversal the provider is god
and he receives the the honor
and the glory it is he that makes the
seed
it is he that makes the seed grow
it is he that produces the seed and the
fruit
here the earth is worshipped and god is
ignored
and that's exactly what they want and
therefore this pagan philosophy by this
pagan pope
is being presented to the world as the
model for everything that has to take
place
every country must implement ladau to
see
i don't even want to read it can i skip
to the next slide before
i have a nausea attack
so it's got to be linked to the common
good
always and we saw in that quote from the
roman catholic catechism that the common
good is always linked to
sunday sunday you cannot separate or not
no so the common good has become global
and nations
it's a very strong word must
associate for their own benefit francis
said
noting that some nations today
have a spirit of opposition rather than
cooperation
the pub called building the common good
of humanity
a necessary and essential element for
the world
balance let us not forget that the
common good is always linked to
sunday sunday pope francis said
that when a supranational
common good is clearly identified
as in the case of climate change or
human trafficking
it necessitates a special legal
authority capable of facilitating
solutions so we need a world body
yes to make sure that everybody adheres
now martin countries that do not
adhere to the pandemic measures
are they punished yes leaders
that do not adhere to it are they
punished
they not only punished they vanished
they vanish
yes they vanish we've had a couple of
african leaders
vanish now where would now we're deep
into conspiracy theories
all healthy men in the
early 60s or late 50s
so whether they disappeared
naturally or not it is interesting that
they were all
anti the agenda let's leave it at that
and what's also interesting to note here
is that he says it has become global
there's common good yes that means the
plan is in place
correct they're ready to correct
and if it is always linked to sunday
will the sunday be part of it
definitely so here's the independent
catholic news and it says
jubilee for the earth looking to
laudato see weak
now weak has a cycle doesn't it martin
yes
so jubilee for the earth is the theme of
autumn
season of creation and a creation sunday
in september will be introduced
jubilee for the earth is a timely theme
for the season of creation
first of september to the 4th of october
bishop mark stringer of
troy's co-president of pax christie said
last month
lauda to see is a monumental gift which
would become more and more
our charter in the post-coronavirus era
my charter is the book of revelation
and the words of our lord throughout the
entire bible
that's my charter that'll chart my path
correct there's a
lutheran world federation so it's not
only a catholic issue
saying exactly the same thing jubilee
for the earth
invites us to consider the integral
relationship between
rest for the earth and ecological
economic
social and political ways of living
this particular year the need for just
and sustainable systems has been
revealed
by the far reaching effects of the
global
covet 19 pandemic
so the churches have changed their
gospel message
into a gaia message that's it that's
what it
leads to leads to and the european
sunday alliance the right to disconnect
and the need for european weekly common
day
of rest invitation to the european
sunday alliance
webinar first june 2021
isn't an agenda definitely
so the webinar follows up from the
recent
activities on the right to disconnect
and aims to raise awareness on the need
to establish
at the eu level a weekly common day of
rest for all
eu citizens are the trade unions on
board
oh yes one of the means to bring about a
time of trouble such as never was
who created them the roman catholic
church
it's it's it's getting boring already it
is because the thing is now and
you show all of this and still they say
oh there's no there's nothing
there's nothing on the horizon nothing
though
well here's earth beat from june 11
2021 102 faith leaders
rally 400 percent clean energy
as key cog in biden's job plan
that's interesting that was the goal of
organizers of a june 9 rally in
washington dc to gather 100 pastors
rabbis and other religious leaders to
vocalize their support
for president joe biden's job plan
and to promise to establish a hundred
percent
clean energy standard for by the year
2035.
has there been a change in gospel
proclamation
yes why would you be appointed as a
pastor
to do what what's the job of a pastor
to preach the gospel and make disciples
correct
more than 3 000 faith leaders signed a
letter
organized by interfaith power and light
urging congress to back a clean energy
standard
etc etc signed by a hundred pastors
professors and evangelical leaders
has the commission of the church been
successfully changed yes
the main mission is now
climate-oriented climate so here we have
the world economic forum
11th of june 2021 the challenge
for g7 leaders vaccinate the world
and be bolder on climate and they're all
practicing social
distancing until the party here is over
then social distancing was no longer
necessary
they were very very buddy-buddy we could
show all those pictures but we don't
have no we don't have to
we don't have to so this is all
a game a charade
and here is a very interesting article
from the tablet
as the g7 begins the world
needs climate sundays and
wild christians more than
ever so now the christian world
has been integrated into the climate
change
change agenda and
that linked to the common good
that being linked to sunday at its heart
all of it coming together yes nothing on
the horizon
and who sits behind all of this wrong
wrong this year with the uk hosting
critical un international climate
negotiations cop 26 in november i'm
looking forward to that date
this is becoming so interesting
christians in this country have a unique
opportunity to
influence if we act together that's why
a rocha uk has joined with nearly
30 other charities and denominations
including
kaifard christian a church of england
church of scotland church of wales
to run the climate sunday initiative
what i don't know
what to say anymore there's nothing to
say everything is there
it's a fulfillment of prophecy people
are so
being kept busy by all this other
nonsense
that they don't see what's going on and
if you they mention this
yes you're a conspiracy theorist
exactly but this is not a conspiracy
theory all the churches are on board
yes but the churches have been divested
of their heart
and it has been replaced with a pagan
philosophy
run by a pagan priesthood
and their aim is to bring
in sunday legislation via the back door
they don't even have to use rome
don't even have to push them themselves
no they're getting all these people to
do it for them
so it's fascinating to me that people
are
staring at the front door waiting for
something to come in
and meantime the back door is wide open
it's probably already in
exactly so here
u.n climate change conference uk 2021
uniting the world to tackle climate
change
this is what where we heading so the uk
will host the 26th u.n
climate change conference of the parties
cop 26 in glasgow
on the 1st to the 12th of november 2021.
the cop26 summit will bring parties
together to
accelerate action towards the goals of
the paris agreement
and the un framework convention on
climate change
the uk is committed to working with all
countries and joining forces with civil
societies
companies and people in the front line
of climate change to inspire climate
action ahead of cop
26. did we just read that
in the predictions made in the
sustainable prince
yes 1998. they already said this is
what's going to be so now we're at the
implementation stage
i'm wondering martin do you think we'll
have a couple of climate calamities just
before this
i think so we had it before the previous
one do you think we'll have some super
hot days
maybe some record events taking place
storms
whatever it's very probable very
probable right
so martin we had this video before
we started off with it we started off
with it and
series so like a bookend let's put it at
the end
and let's hear from a skull and bones
member
chapter 3 2 2 of the illuminati
john kerry one of those
papal nights to tell us
exactly who is the man to be trusted
in this issue if i may i just want to
put in something
just before people get excited about him
being
a democrat in the previous government
bull bar is a knight of columbus
it doesn't matter on which side of the
political spectrum there are
they still fall under rome correct so
we'll play it again
to create our bookend
you're on a very important mission here
to europe
can you tell us why is it important to
include a visit with the pope
during your visit to europe to talk
about climate change
well the pope is one of the great voices
of reason and compelling moral authority
on the subject of the climate crisis
he's been ahead of the curve
he's been a leader his encyclical la
dato c
is really very very powerful document
eloquent and morally very persuasive
and i think that um his voice will be a
very important voice leading up to and
through the glasgow conference
how can the united states as a power
and the hoist see as a much smaller
country but nonetheless as moral and
spiritual authority
uh collaborate in the fight against
climate change
well the holy father is one of if not
the one of the most powerful voices on
the planet
and he's been extraordinary in the
eloquence of his
call on people to to to step up and be
reasonable and to
live out our responsibility as human
beings in
caring for god's creation and
and we all have to be stewards of that
creation that's his message
uh but because he is above politics and
outside of
the hurley burley of day to day
national conflict etc
i think he can sort of you know shake
people a little bit and bring them to
the table with a
better sense of our common obligation
and i think the holy father speaks with
special authority to our sense of
obligation to each other and the ways in
which
we need to all step up now together
given the divisions of the world and
some of the polarization
and the ideology and conflict
that voice is more important than ever
so martin that voice is more important
than ever
and i think we have done what we can
to show what the real agenda is
of this organization
and i think we should close with this
text from isaiah
chapter 51 lift up your eyes to the
heavens and look upon the earth beneath
for the heavens shall vanish away like
smoke
and the earth shall wax old like a
garment
and they that dwell therein shall die in
like manner but my salvation
shall be forever and my righteousness
shall not be abolished
the text is quite clear that the earth
will wear out like a garment
it is coming to a close yes
and the idea of regenerating it
back into its former glory is a vain
idea because the course of history
has come to a close now i'm not
propagating
environmental destruction no we have to
do what we can
because we are stewards of the earth
but the ultimate solution
lies in salvation my
salvation shall be forever
and my righteousness shall not
be abolished that is unchangeable
correct everything else is changeable
and it is time for humanity to choose
sides
as for me and my house and i'm sure
yours too
i think we will choose the salvation
that is in christ
and leave the gaia hypothesis and the
pagan rituals
to those that wish to follow that root
amen
let's pray heavenly father
thank you for the gospel of salvation
thank you that there is an immovable
rock
thank you that there's an anchor that
will never let go of its hold
thank you lord that you have shown us
all these things
in your word and that you have
tried everything possible to prepare us
for what
lies ahead help us to make right choices
in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you